whenever you redistribute income
you reduce total income if I tax people
who work
and I pay people who don't work
do I need to say the next sentence to
you you're going to get a lot of people
not working
[Music]
now very simply
redistribution
is when you take from someone
who has a little bit more
and you give it to someone
who has a little bit less what you're
doing is redistributing income from the
person who has a little bit more and
giving it to a person who has a little
bit less that is redistribution now when
you take from someone who has a little
bit more
[Music]
you reduce that person's incentives to
produce
and that person will produce a little
bit less in other words when you take
from someone through a tax when you take
from someone who has a little bit more
that person's incentives are reduced and
that person will produce a little bit
less than he or she otherwise would have
produced period
number two when you give to someone who
has a little bit less
you provide that person with an
alternative source of income other than
working
and that person too will produce a
little bit less than he or she otherwise
would have produced the theorem here is
really very straightforward and very
simple whenever you redistribute incomes
you always reduce total income period
redistribution of wealth are the laugh
has always been very suspicious of that
because what welfare spending does is he
said many times is okay you take from
people who have a lot okay but what are
they doing with that extra money those
people who have a lot
the last dollar they have is the dollar
that they are most risky with usually
and dollars that rich people are most
risky with usually in many cases result
in the Enterprises which transform life
in the Next Generation so you're taking
about the most powerful dollar you could
in this economy and then giving it to
people to encourage them not to work so
it's a kind of a double supply side
undercutting of the economy by taxi
people who work you reduce their
incentives to hire people and by paying
people who don't work you reduce their
incentives to produce work and so you're
going to reduce total work effort in the
system the more you redistribute income
the greater will be the decline in total
income if you are able
to redistribute all income so that
everyone comes out exactly the same
if you're able to do that
there will be no income whatsoever in
order to have everyone come out exactly
the same
exactly the same what you have to do is
you have to tax everyone
who makes above the average income
100 of the excess
and you have to subsidize everyone below
the average income
up to the average income that's the only
way you're going to get everyone to come
out exactly those people who make more
than the average have to be packs right
down to the average and those people who
make less than the average have to be
subsidized right up to the average now
if you actually really did that if you
actually taxed everyone and made above
the average income one hundred percent
of the excess
and if you actually didn't subsidize
everyone below the average income up to
the average income I'll stipulate today
counselor
all incomes will be exactly the same and
they will be at zero there will be no
incentive for anyone to ever produce any
goods and services so total goods and
service production will be exactly equal
that is the theorem pure and simple
[Music]